هذا العام سبق عيد الام شهر رمضان بيومين
فرصه ثانويه لشراء الهدايا للامهات فكيف
تاثرت بدخول رمضان بعض الابناء يحاولون
شراء هديه تجمع المناسبتين ولهذا يلجاون
للاماكن التي تبيع منتجات يدويه الصنع انا
جايه انا ومامتي علشان لو حاجه هي بتحب
الحاجات اللي والهند والحاجات دي فهي
لو عجبتها هجيب لها حاجات عشان عيد الام
بعض منتجي السلع اليدوي يستعدوا من خلال
تصميمات ذات علاقه بالمناسبتين معا وفي
هذه الحاله وجدنا الكثير ممن دمج رمضان في
عيد الام اللي بيدور على عيد الام موجوده
بيدور على رمضان موجود في حاجات عاملاها
ميكس ما بين الاثنين يعني زي مثلا
كاتبه عليها رمضان احلى مع جدتي رمضان
احلى مع امي فتبقى هديه الاثنين مع بعض
عيد الام ورمضان كل فتره من دول بيبقى
ليها فيه معين في البيت فمثلا في رمضان
كلنا بنجهز ديكورات رمضان والبيت كله
بيقلب ديكولات رمضان ونشيل الديكورات
العاديه
في كريسماس برده البيت كله بيقلب كريسماس
فيعني اعتقد ان هي السيزونز دي بتبقى حلوه
يعني وسواء تزامنا عيد الام مع رمضان ام
لا فدائما ما تستعد ومتاجر وبيع الزهور كل
عام بكميات كبيره من السلعه الاكثر مبيعا
في هذه المناسبه تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره